whether it was about money morals or
frustration with show business it's not
uncommon for stars to leave shows at the
height of their popularity what's more
unusual is that Sometimes they come back
though he had appeared in several
high-profile movies and television shows
prior actor David Duchovny didn't fully
break out and to stardom until Landing
the part of Special Agent Fox Mulder in
The X-Files his dry delivery was
perfectly suited to Mulder and his
chemistry with Jillian Anderson who
played Mulder's partner Dana Scully was
undeniable one of the first big
non-comedy hits for the still fairly new
Fox network The X-Files was extremely
popular in the 90s and quickly developed
a passionate cult following that remains
to this day despite all that Duchovny
left the show after his contract was up
at the end of season seven in part
because he felt Fox wasn't giving him a
fair share of the money it was earning
from the series and its various
distribution deals while he was only
really absent for part of season 8
during which time Mulder was fittingly
abducted by aliens Duchovny was not a
main cast member and only appeared in a
handful of season 9 episodes when the
X-Files returned in 2016 however
Duchovny was fully back in action for
Seasons 10 and 11. he was also the top
built star of the second X-Files movie I
want to believe released during the
Hiatus between between season 9 and
season 10.
of the six actors that comprise the main
cast of the long-running medical drama
ER the first of them to leave was Sherry
Stringfield she left behind the
character Dr Susan Lewis after three
seasons to pursue a more traditional
life I want to have my life you know
like I want to have a real relationship
in an interview with variety Stringfield
recalled that the acting age returned
once she'd started her own family this
would eventually lead her to come back
to the show full time beginning with
season eight she had left the series on
good terms with the showrunners so
returning was fairly straightforward for
her stringfield's second stint playing
Dr Lewis as a main cast member was even
longer than her first and she stayed
with the show until the beginning of
season 12. in addition along with all
five of the other original main cast
members Stringfield returned once again
to make special appearances during the
15th and final season of ER
until Keenan Thompson overtook him Daryl
Hammond was the longest running cast
member of Saturday Night Live even still
Hammond holds various other records
related to the show including the
distinction of being the oldest cast
member in the history of SNL reaching
the age of 53 during his 14th and final
season on the show Hammond left the
series in 2009 at the end of season 34
though he wouldn't make history as the
first and thus far only former cast
member to ever return to Saturday Night
Live in a full-time capacity after
longtime announcer Don Pardo died in the
summer of 2014 Hammond came back to SNL
in season 40 to take over Pardo's old
job ladies and gentlemen Pete Davidson
and Leslie Jones
while Hammond has made the occasional
on-camera appearance beginning with his
portrayal of Donald Trump in season 41
he is largely stuck to announcing and
other voice over duties on the show he
remains the full-time announcer to this
day
after four seasons of playing series
matriarch Florida Evans on Good Times
Esther Rolle left the cast due to issues
she had with the rising popularity as
well as the portrayal of the show's
breakout character though good times was
originally meant to focus on Florida and
her husband James their oldest son JJ
became a fan favorite and the show was
retooled to fit his sillier comedic
sensibilities in an interview with Ebony
magazine roll expressed her disdain for
the character of JJ and said that he
perpetuated too many negative
stereotypes about black youth her
co-star John Amos raced similar issues
with the producers which ultimately led
to his firing and the killing off of his
character role wound up leaving
voluntarily over the direction of the
show at the end of season four after
being gone through all of season 5 she
returned to play Florida Evans once more
for the final season of Good Times
one of the main factors that keeps a
show like Gray's Anatomy on the air for
many years is its characters sure
beloved fan favorites that viewers love
to root for are often a series driving
force but antagonistic characters that
fans love to hate are just as important
one character Gray's Anatomy fans are
often outspoken in their hatred for is
Kim ravers Dr Teddy Altman the
cardiothoracic surgeon was a fairly
short-lived character at first only
joining the main cast during season six
and departing by the end of season 8.
however raver eventually came back to
the show to stir up trouble again first
in a recurring role in season 14 and
then once again as a main cast member in
season 15. that makes her one of only
five current Gray's cast members as of
season 19 who goes back as early as
season six raver is also the only actor
thus far to leave the show and come back
in a full-time capacity
as remarkable as it is that The Simpsons
has now soared well past the 30 season
Mark what's almost even more impressive
is that it has managed to retain nearly
all of its original Main and recurring
voice Talent save for those that have
passed away beyond the six actors that
comprise the show's primary main cast
there are a handful of others who show
up in the also starring end credits of
nearly every episode that voiced many of
the show's most popular characters one
voice actor that's been with the show
from season one is Maggie Roswell who
quickly became integral to the series as
she was responsible for voicing such
important characters as mod Flanders
Helen Lovejoy Miss Hoover and Luanne Van
Houten I question the educational value
of this assembly hey it'll be one are
there a few pleasant memories when
they're pumping gas for a living however
Roswell ended up quitting The Simpsons
in 1999 over a pay dispute in which he
says Fox refused to raise her salary to
help cover the cost of flying back and
forth between the show's La Studios and
her home in Denver after Roswell left
mod Flanders was killed off and the
actor's other characters were voiced by
someone else in 2002 Fox agreed to let
Roswell record her lines from home and
she returned to the show where she's
been an also starring cast member for
two decades and Counting
people sometimes forget that the
Jeffersons was actually a spin-off of
All in the Family despite the fact that
various members of the Jefferson Clan
appear in over 30 episodes of the
original series before they were finally
given their own show the actors who
played Louise Jefferson George Jefferson
and Lionel Jefferson on All in the
Family would all make the jump over to
the new show but one of them wouldn't
stay on board for long according to the
television Academy during a company
Christmas party Lionel Jefferson actor
Mike Evans demanded more screen time on
The Jeffersons from showrunner Norman
Lear he even threatened to quit if he
didn't get it instead Evans was fired
from the show on the spot actor Damon
Evans was cast in the role of Lionel for
Seasons two through four with the
character missing from the show entirely
during season five eventually however
Mike Evans returned to the Jeffersons
full-time to play Lionel for seasons 6
and 7 moving to a recurring role for
season 8 and then returning as a guest
star for the 11th and final season
the police procedural genre can provide
a steady long-term paycheck for an actor
if they are so inclined as many
successful crime dramas in this vein can
last for decades this is probably why
Paget Brewster jumped at the chance to
take a role on Criminal Minds as special
agent Emily Prentiss in 2006 despite the
fact that she is also an extremely
talented comedic actor it's been a
mistake
I think so sir Mr plate agent Prentice
in the main cast of Criminal Minds from
season 2 through season 7 though she was
no longer on the show full time after
that point she didn't stay away
completely appearing here and there via
guest spots between season 9 and season
11. she would eventually return to the
series full time when she rejoined the
main cast in season 12 where she has
remained ever since she even reprized
her role in season 16 when the series
was rebranded as Criminal Minds
evolution
there are a few Law and Order franchise
lifers who seem like they are more than
willing to stay on their respective
shows for as long as they exist Law and
Order Special Victims Unit in particular
seems Adept at retaining Talent with
several actors appearing in over 500
episodes of the series Christopher
Maloney seemed to be on that track with
his role as Elliot Stabler but he ended
up leaving after season 12. after almost
10 seasons away Maloney returned to SVU
on a recurring but steady basis
beginning with season 22. meanwhile he
has returned to the broader Law and
Order franchise as a main cast member
with Stabler acting as the primary lead
on the Fairly young law order organized
crime it's likely he only came back to
SVU as a means of cross-promotion for
organized crime but he still made a fair
number of appearances in his original
Law and Order show it remains to be seen
what his presence will be on SVU going
forward who knows maybe he'd be willing
to return full-time if organized crime
doesn't end up sprouting legs long term
Lisa gorinson was the original actor to
portray Becky Connor on the acclaimed
sitcom Roseanne a role she played for
Five Seasons until she went to college
initially gorensen tried to balance her
duties on the show with her Studies by
reducing her role to more of a part-time
recurring presence but it was too much
for Goranson who ultimately had to leave
the series entirely during season 5 in
order to fully concentrate on school
rather than have Becky be absent from
Roseanne in the meantime actor Sarah
chalk was brought in to take over as
Becky for season 6 and season seven
Goranson then returned to take her old
role back over in season 8 though chalk
still had to stand in again for a few
episodes when goranson's school schedule
got in the way the original Becky actor
ended up leaving once more with chalk
taking over the role full-time yet again
for Season 9. 22 years later when
Roseanne returned for its Revival season
it was Goranson back in the role of
Becky aparchy continued to play as the
show transitioned into the Connors The
Following season
given her particularly personal history
with Jean-Luc Picard the Star Trek the
Next Generation character fans were most
excited to see return in Picard was
Beverly Crusher played by Gates McFadden
in both series Beverly's relationship
with the famous captain of the USS
Enterprise has certainly made for some
of the most significant plot lines in
the entire franchise what's particularly
surprising about Dr crusher's popularity
was that she departed from the Next
Generation after season one it turns out
that McFadden didn't get along with
Maurice Hurley one of the show's main
writers and producers at the time and as
a result McFadden was fired at the end
of season one I don't think this is over
yet not by a long shot the fans were not
happy about this change and they never
really embraced her successor Diana
moldauer's Dr Pulaski so when both
moldauer and Hurley decided to leave the
next generation at the end of season 2.
McFadden was invited back and returned
to the show as a main cast member for
its remaining Five Seasons as well as
all of the next Generation movies
foreign